joining us here fresh back from augusta
national is a man who gave us a nice
little heads up couple weeks ago that
the tiger woods returned to
competitive golf and at the masters was
uh was definitely not nothing and he now
joins us after scottie scheffler slips
on the green jacket from the worldwide
leader in sports a fellow best studio
host nominee for the emmy award scott
van pelt how are you doing svp
i'm well i'm well and uh congrats by the
way on on that nomination so he's nice
to be included in that and that list and
sincerely humbling and all that so that
that's uh that's uh nice of you to say
and congrats and i'll see you in new
york i hope right back at you right back
at you
although that was not the sentiment you
you told ernie johnson on the text
exchange we all had privately that i'm
not bringing public scott yeah i said i
i hate ernie johnson i said oh wait did
i send this to everyone
yeah you replied to all um yeah well i
mean it was we obviously knew what we
were doing ernie is one of the kindest
gentlest one most wonderful souls in the
world and we all need him because he
wins everything
you know let's just call it what it is
not to put too fine a point on it yeah
you're not wrong you're not wrong
although i got enough
he's got it's like cost us back in the
day i used to lose to him now i lose to
ernie but you know maybe one of these
days or i'll just be susan lucci it's
fine yeah
um
the uh
where do we want to start with i had i
was on with my dear friend here in in dc
uh who has a podcast and he said that
the story of the weekend's tiger woods
and i said hold on hold on hold on i'm
with you
i know where you going guy that's number
one in the world who's won three of his
last five events shows up and wins
that's the story of the weekend
now if you want to tell me the
overarching headline was tiger i'm not
arguing we certainly our ratings
benefited i'm sure cbs's will have as
well
and tiger is a massive story but scotty
sheppard winning is is the headline and
rightly so you win and you're the
headline well i'm with you um and and i
figured again who better to have on than
you to tell me who this guy is and where
all this came from right i mean middle
middle of february nobody had any idea
um that this could be
happening no no here's what's
interesting is that
and and god these last couple years
because of of the way things have
happened and it's so easy to forget when
and where and what right because it's
just this fog
and
in november
2020 when the masters was played then
i went over no one was there it's empty
and i went over to introduce myself to
scotty because i hadn't met him but
prior to that in august at the pga
championship in harding park out in san
francisco he played brilliantly and was
in the final group and it was just
obvious that even though he was new to
the stage he just something about him
the way he carried himself he was young
but he felt
mature now i don't say oh just felt very
mature and so i just walked over and he
was coming off the 18th and i said hey
and we'd be asked for a few minutes and
i just said man it's you're going to be
out here a long time and have a blast
and be great you're going to win a ton
because i said it because i thought it
and he hadn't yet
and then in phoenix he wins and then he
wins in orlando at bay hill and then he
wins a match play so that's a completely
different deal and now he wins a major
and so
i think in the game rich people thought
he was a dude like he had it he was
going to be a guy and then the ryder cup
too i don't want to miss that he right
i think john rom there and beat the then
world number one and just put on a show
and so at every turn he's shown that he
had the goods but for it all to happen
at warp speed and to to ramp up to
number one and then win as world number
one and to win the way he did that's the
kind of stuff that makes you have to
really stop and ask all right well what
are we what are we talking about what
what type of trajectory are we like
trajec
trajectory i can't do it trajectory
emmy nominee scott
we're all together i'm there for you i
want you to the sentence structure yeah
what kind of a trajectory are we on well
it was it was like an elmer fudd thing
that happened
anyway
what i'm trying to say is he's good and
he's really he's really playing some
good golf rich i want to tell you
but again like we're we're i know he's
from jersey right and he went to the he
went to he's a longhorn like i guess
many other terrific professionals who
wear green jackets are right and and so
right texas kid like the story goes that
he used to show up at the golf course
wearing wearing long pants in the summer
because he wanted to carry himself like
a tour pro and that's what that's how he
visualized himself it's how he saw
himself and you know kind of
spoke it into existence if you will i
mean he's just it's just the way
and and this is
i'm not in in no way is it critical it's
just it's just it's different i i really
like kala morikawa uh he lives in vegas
he's not flashy he's incredibly composed
too guy from cow really mature but i
think he's he's got a little bit
there's just a little bit more
something a little and that's style but
just maybe feels like he could be got a
big personality that he can show you
right that bright smile that lights up a
room justin thomas he's got a whole
bunch of swagger and and
on a big stage loves it wants to strut
on a big stage scotty sheffler feels
more like a guy that's just sort of
gives you a nod and a smile
and not not a whole lot more he just
he's about to work and and the results
speak for themselves it's it's
it's not unexpected
that he's won but look no one expects
someone to win four out of six starts
and go from not ranked number one to a
pretty strong grip on it well i i when i
said he's a jersey kid he was born in
new jersey i'm aware he went to a high
school that i guess
others went to like matthew stafford is
it true matthew stafford and clayton
kershaw were on the same team too that's
the first i'd heard that mentioned
that's what an amazing cowinky thing
yeah did you know ryan fitzpatrick went
to harvard too are you aware of that
scotty yeah jerome bettis was it was is
it was it
back to back to where he was from super
bowl yeah and detroit that's where he
was from um you know i'm just throwing
these things out
you know what you're a [ __ ] we're just
trying to put pieces together we're just
all puzzle makers right here uh scott
van pelt on the on the rich eisen show
okay and and the uh uh
the holdouts from the side bunker on 18
with mcelroy and morocco that was some
of the most outstanding
masters moments i've seen in a long time
that that got me off the couch that was
awesome and we needed it we needed it
because scheduler had grabbed had put a
stranglehold on the tournament to such a
degree that it was you're looking for
something that was awesome just because
rory
is a guy who as we all know needs the
masters to finish the slam and for
whatever reason has just gotten off to
poor starts and it's kind of baffling as
to why
and
in the game people not if this is not a
criticism by any stretch but when he
starts playing well on the weekend it's
just the old oh here comes rory for
another backdoor top 10. well he's he's
played so well on the weekends where he
hasn't been part of the story line and
then you look back at the results and
you go oh wow he did finish top ten you
just never he wasn't part of the main
fabric of the story well yesterday was
different because not only did he play
well enough to become top ten but he was
playing well enough that you had to
entertain the thought that if something
went wrong with scheffler well maybe he
could post a score and then when he
holds out on 18 and the place goes
berserk
and then morocco matches it and the
reaction of those two
with one another right like your rory
was cheering him on the same way
morikawa was cheering on rory and then
mcelroy had that i don't know what to do
with my hands thing i that i don't know
what happened like it was like the club
ejected from his hands he just kept
putting like what are you doing with
your hands bro
what is this thing you're doing uh but
it was it was it was spectacular
mark told me afterwards i've never heard
aurora like that and then he heard
another one because it was for him it
was tremendous and again those are two
great talents
but it speaks to what shuffler did over
the course of three and a half days that
in terms of who's going to win and lose
it didn't make any difference it was
just a nice foot footnote to sandy
birdies like that you know so scott van
pelt here how about that you go you go
bunker to bunker and hold out and you
don't win the hole with you you know
when you're settling up with your buddy
like that guy we have the hole but right
and then and then one of one of them and
one of them uh
caps a 64 on sunday with it and doesn't
even come within shots of the tournament
you know it's
again that's that's what speaks to
scheffler's
he came down to butler cabin on friday
and um
and it was he hadn't won from the lead
and it's wild how
in sports not just golf but
certainly in golf but playing with the
lead there's a burden to that there's
something about
being
freed up when you're chasing and you saw
that from mcelroy right maybe you kick
you take on shots maybe you wouldn't
otherwise and i i said to scotty look
you won in phoenix and you won an
orlando trailing i'm not trying to say
there's anything bad about leading by
five obviously but it's just different
and i think he spoke to that after he
won that when he woke up sunday he was
emotional like i don't know if i'm ready
for this because that place is different
man like you win that and it's you're
different for the rest of your life
you're a masters champion and i thought
it was interesting to hear him
so honestly share what that what that
the weight of that is just the
expectation because we've seen people
stumble certainly famously in in that
spot and he didn't and
at such a young age to to kind of wobble
a bit early and then you know steady
himself and win i think it's just from
start to finish it's just a hell of a
show from a young man scott van pelt
here on the rich eisen show fresh back
from augusta national great coverage on
espn cbs the whole family uh covering uh
the masters so um let's get into tiger
any idea
what he did between rounds to get ready
i mean that saturday it was 50 degrees
outside
just a crusher for any human being let
alone somebody his age coming back from
what he was coming back from do you have
like a
any what was his regimen you have the
the old flowering peach hyperbaric
chamber or something like that like what
do you have
let me start just with the the hardest
thing for people in our business to ever
say i don't know i don't know
specifically he he you know he doesn't
always he doesn't connect all the dots
for us he did mention a lot of ice ice
baths and how much they suck i believe
i'm quoting him directly
and they're just trying to reduce
swelling because
he's not
that far removed from this this horrific
injury to his leg
and you saw it take its toll over the
course of the four days and as you point
out saturday was legitimately not just
cold for gus it was cold day the wind it
was just it kind of felt like a fall
football day like an ann arbor you know
saturday in november it felt like that
um and so he's managing more than most
but i don't i don't know the specifics i
think
what's most interesting coming out of it
is another question we don't know the
answer to and that's when will we see
him again um i think
look no secret pga's on our network it'd
be great for us if he's on just because
obviously people turn up to see him if
he doesn't maybe the us open but he did
say he'd play the open at st andrews
which is his favorite course in the
world so that so that's good news if
nothing else we know we've got one more
major um to see him but
it's it's clear there's a lot of work to
do uh for him to physically get that leg
stronger so that it's not such a uh
you know such a challenge for him just
to get around for 18.
so okay so maybe we see him uh before
then but what i mean
all in all though just the mere fact
that he did it
made the cut um at one point thursday if
i'm not mistaking it he had a putt to
share the lead
right he was in the mix for i don't know
i cuz i don't remember where m was
in relation to where tiger was but i
mean it he was look he was under par he
shot 71 which totally
meant we had to rethink what we what
might happen right and and then
and look you you've covered the guy for
years too prior to to changing hats and
becoming you know the face of the nfl
network i mean you remember that there
was
no
there was no world in which 78 78 on the
weekend in a major would be greeted with
a giant smile and him saying he was
thankful right but that's what you saw
sunday and i thought that was really uh
a window into
what the week was about for him uh i'm
back i'm trying i'm in the arena played
played one good round now i just got to
figure out how to get around for three
more days and he did and in the end was
he at close to winning no but that the
genuine joy i felt like you saw from him
and the reception he got from the
patrons there at augusta national
actually you know people all around the
world like they're sitting on their
couch smiling going right on this dude's
back in it you know and that's more than
we thought not that long ago how big is
butler kevin how big is that not
enormous not enormous it's a but big
enough for uh
big enough for the people that need to
be in there
but what what is it normally just like
some folks who are done with a round
they go hang out in the cabin or just
it's cabin
when you go down to uh to be there but
uh
uh it's it's it's just insane rich i
mean we've known each other a long long
time yeah and it's just so hard to
explain i'm sure you have those moments
in your life
in your work where you just look around
and you shake your head and you think
wow you know here i sit right i mean
it's three eastern and the masters comes
on the air and and you're the one
talking
it's just
absolutely absurd so
tiger's not the only guy thankful down
there that week that's for sure you're
sitting in there for two days and that's
the office and it's just
such a
such a joy to do it so i mean not to pry
but i'll do it anyway so if like you say
you need a pen do you go searching
through drawers in case bill gates left
one from a few weeks ago or something
like i'm seriously like what is it
there's furniture there's a bed there's
is that what it is they've moved
everything out of the way is so that
there are just the chairs that you see
there in front of the fireplace and then
then what you what the camera doesn't
see is is
how it is in any studio it's all the
things that make it work right the
lights the there's monitors that you can
watch
um you know the action there's
leaderboards that are telling you what's
happening on every single hole that are
just you know to your in your sight line
beyond the cameras yeah um but i mean
you know this i'll just say i'll just
put it this way
if you needed anything someone would
sort that out for you
you have to go rummaging through the
prank please no like where the hell is
the pen i need a piece of paper you give
me the paper
all right and then all of a sudden some
member strolls in like what are you
doing in here scott like you don't want
to do you know none of that
i stay i try to i try to keep it between
the mustard and the mayonnaise my man i
stay where i'm meant to be you know
i don't wander off into the second cut i
stay right here
and uh
i don't go i don't go searching but you
don't need to everything's right where
you need it you know you know what's so
cool about about that place is cam smith
comes in after the first round and the
guys just played this brilliant round
he's 68
four under
and after we got done and he looks at me
and he's a super understated guy and he
says
mate i've never been more nervous in my
life
and i thought
i mean that's butler cabin you know the
idea is since he's been playing the game
he thought someday i'll get down there
sadly for him it was thursday with me
and not sunday with nats but maybe
someday
maybe someday
scott you're the man thanks again i'll
see you in new york uh emmy night if not
sooner you're the best thanks pal i
appreciate you my man i'll i'll see you
soon and thanks for having me anytime
thank you that's scott van pelt here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here